il s'est complètement foiré la dernière
fois et sa connexion internet aussi mais
aujourd'hui il est de retour pour
prendre sa revanche et tué tous et fdp
temps qui se dresseront sur son chemin
messieurs dames un tonnerre
d'applaudissements vos oui ici du hockey
aujourd'hui et sur dia poillion va
s'appeler 13 taille peur la peur la peur
je suis désolé des ddd sg gr and her and
arrest
être y arriver l'eau l'arête voilà en
agence ou est animateur de colonie de
vacances à l'égard des enfants arrêtez
de vous battre
sac à un petit résumé ça va nous faire
du bien ça allait sac à merde
franchement c'est le cas elle est hyper
violente ça se trouve c'est la caste qui
t'était que personne ne veut jouer parce
qu'elle est trop forte je m'en bats les
couilles je suis un connard en donald
one va c'est bien mignon tes conneries
mais un moment à un moment il faut que
t'arrêtes walla les amis c'est parti
pour aller défoncer le premier de la
game aux mondiaux 11 rôle le premier il
joue d'un truc que moi mais on en est
pas ma voix est là bas moi ah non là ça
va chier au regard des quatre élèves
qu'à sa mère et mieux lui a dit a jamais
joyau dépit de katia un retour à l'école
mais j'étais loin de me le faire
[ __ ] il fait mal non ouais mais y met
des coups de cul imtu mais [ __ ] bon
bah les couches quoi ça pète un câble a
validé cette super un vrai plaisir
ok c'est le retour de lucas au char à
c'est lui le premier [ __ ] ils mettent
infernale à batz qui one shot mes trucs
en fait c'est ça en fait si vous faire
ses classes et tu viens au milieu et tu
pètes toutes les formes tranquille en
plus les protégés de tête ou qui te
protège bref c'est trop beau on craint
rien ni personne aidée mais tu vas
mourir je les trouvais
qui est le médoc les mecs c'est y pas
ait on n'a plus rien se tapper qui nous
casse les couilles bec maywald mesnel
j'en peux plus tu achètes belgique spe
pendant une heure et demie pour mourir
quand même un gros qu ok là mon gars
d'apprendre la spécialisation a
sincèrement hunter hunter oh là là ça
fait mal là c'est une bataille de sniper
mont-garin v1 sur heureuse comme à
l'ancienne la trop de vie fait trop mal
mec mais regarde mais je suis ou très
bon hockey bulle de la mort bulle de la
mort attention ce n'est assassin je suis
sûr que ça fait super mal
les amis à un moment j'en ai marre de
toutes ces conneries c'est parti
oh [ __ ] le deuxième sur sa canne au
mur at il est pas content le mec qui
nous lâche pas il a pas de vie de sa vie
c'est ce à quoi que quelqu'un m'aide
mais [ __ ] mais s'amuser là mais non
mais non mais non mais n'a ensuite eu un
truc mais je vais tuer quelqu'un j'en ai
marre j'en ai mal au kkk n'abandonne pas
notre rêve d'être le premier sur ce
[ __ ] de jeu ça va arriver à un moment
donné vous le savez je le sais ils le
savent
regardez le lui comment il compte qu'on
va se faire mais que ce genre va se
faire il est tellement lendemain
regarder l'onema l'ont même allons mais
mal il coupera pas rien n'y fait rien my
fucking god bon bah écoutes je demande à
ça ça un mal réagi me fait chier bargach
des pav
non j'ai raté ma vie ça sont pris à moi
ils se sont pris à mon moral ils s'en
sont pris à mon casque ça va chier hop
là un petit truc chouette à
l'intervention va pas se mentir ça fait
toujours plaisir là bas mais du boulet
speed comme ça nos balles de snipers
vont hyper vite vers des côtes est qu il
va aller en discothèque
oh oui on va le bounty xd il va trouver
ça beaucoup moins drôle d'un coût de la
vie on a eu avec parker d'apple one shot
mais j'ai pris une forme ça va tuer le
coup hockey dans à level on se
transforme-t-elle à transformer à toi
mais c'est trop fort mec mais regardez
c'est trop fort félix p o
ça brasse mais [ __ ] ça a ni deux les
gens c'est juste violence fiction finit
pas premier avec ça les gars vous jure
je me tourne le torse
tu fais quoi ali arrête mali je voulais
pas faire ça mec tu vois bien que je
suis un peu trompeur pourra pas se
mentir il fait quoi lui
toi mais les gars arrêtez vous à tête
j'ai pas qu'un lézard tu vas pas
t'attaquer à crocodiles tu vois attrapez
les tous y compris pikachu
est-ce qu'on va pas pouvoir se le faire
lui là il en panique il en panique il
est mort il est mort il est mort au hall
a défoncé on est destiné à avoir une
grande estime
ça veut rien dire m génie qui est ce que
c'est un problème pour le même génie qui
n'ont pas du tout il est mort n'était
minaj
nicki minaj oh mais tu fais quoi s à
m'attaquer mettez tous patiné au il fit
état au secours lui ami daniel daniel je
sais que c'est ton copain christophe
mais arrête daniel daniel tu arrêtes
daniel tu as well as je suis désolé
j'étais plus du gange publierait les
enfants un jeu menace j'exécute passer à
une mini ont regardé l'honneur allez
rennes retourner avec mika sera mon
grand allez allez allez
mais mon cas on est tous ses fils
devraient juste turquie à trouver vas-y
retrouvons le but allez c'est parti
direction cendres la map les gars là on
est des terres cache pas que j'ai un
petit stress et on est un [ __ ]
d'america sniper a dit un peu de
champagne est un peu de chemin ce sont
des mecs on va pour les tuant tous
secondes séparent regarder olalalala on
notera prendre un max de level yassine
est dans la merde
il est dans la mairie et de la mairie de
remercier dans la merde mon dieu oh
[ __ ] il est où le leader ya pas la
flèche ou et la flèche qui m'indique oui
il est là où il est là où on va se faire
mais le leader et actu mais il est là
aux mondiaux ni repos en vue ni repos en
vue il se déplace trop vite ça va être
chaud mais le mec il a il a mis trop
nouveau mode speed ne pourra jamais
l'avoir car les années où s'est décidé
in désolé les gars bah ouais bah non
mais je vais même pas crier c'est facile
d'être premiers dégâts voilà le travail
est fait je vous dis abonnez vous
franchement c'était physique oui belge
ancien pote cette vidéo n'était pas là
mais ça vous a plu un jeu poyaud
terminée
je vais devenir sans trop de difficultés
cette fois ci non plus donc voila
c'était plutôt trop tu as les fines et
le camp de rien on en a chié mais on l'a
fait bravo avouera ne fait ça c'est
débile ats deux prochaines heures la
fenêtre regarder portez vous bien sûr
tout le monde pousse